All right, so the first thing to do here is to go to Spotlight and open Xcode.
There it is.
I will click on the Create a new Xcode project link.
Now, on the left hand side here,
you will notice that there are two categories, iOS and OS X.
These are two different operating systems that Apple makes.
iOS is for mobile devices and OS X is for desktop.
Since I'm interested in making a mobile application,
I will make sure that application is selected under iOS.
All of the options that you see here like Single View,
Game, these are templates that we can use to create projects.
You can think of them as templates that you can see when creating a presentation
for instance.
Single View, is the simplest template around.
It is a great place to start for a lot of apps.
It is also somewhat similar to a blank template when you
are making a presentation.
So I will make sure I select this and hit Next.
I will name our app Pitch Perfect.
[SOUND] By the way,
this name will also appear just below the apps icon on the user's phone.
I've added a link in the instructor notes that highlights recommendations from
Apple on how to choose an effective name for your application.
Under Organization Name, Xcode has already entered Udacity.
You can enter either your name or the name of your organization in this box.
For the Organization Identifier, Apple recommends that you reverse the address
of your personal website or the website of your organization.
So here I have added com.udacity.
Now the reason for us reversing this address is because we
want to make this bundle identifier unique for our app.
I am developing this app in Swift so I will pick that.
Under Devices I will choose iPhone.
Now, the reason why I am picking this value is because I want to
focus my teaching efforts for this course.
I could have made an app for both iPad and iPhone.
By the way, you can change this setting later on if you choose.
I'm going to hit Next.
And select a folder where I want to save my project.
I have a folder called iOS Apps on my desktop.
And I will hit Create.
And voila, we've made an empty app.
Now there's a lot going on here in Xcode.
Let's dive into it in the next video.